the fans would love to see you play
she-hulk have you seen this fan campaign
that is so flattering that is one of the
best characters in that universe I would
die to play that role I think I
definitely haven't upped my workout
since reading some of those things but
also it would I think be really exciting
for fans to see some of these characters
that will kind of decided are one thing
just sort of be imagined in a different
way I think we have continually seen
that especially in the last like I would
say five years and our superheroes like
the idea of what a superhero could be is
really shifting and changing and that's
exciting because the people buying
tickets those movies are starting to see
themselves and that's wonderful and not
just a beautiful that's what's really
exciting whether or not it it's me which
I would of course died a place into
challenging incredible role but honestly
like just you know the exciting part is
that people like me or you know some of
the other fan cats have seen are like
tracy said who i think is incredible and
such a talent those are amazing choices
to be thrown into the mix like that it's
really cool
Stephanie Beatriz reacting to the fan
campaign to get her cast as a
live-action she-hulk on it Disney Plus
at NBC's comedy starts here event in LA
Brooklyn nine-nine back for Season seven
what is gonna surprise the fans about
this season I think what's going to be
surprising is how much money we can fit
in each episode I mean really when you
break it down it's about 22 minutes and
we are so
oh my god if you're not going so that
means we're going fast are we going fast
can I want tell if we're going fastly
we're going fast at all in any way
whatsoever I feel like we're going slow
in every way whatsoever Koeppen how do
you feel great excellent amazing I feel
better than I've ever felt at a moment
in my entire life so we're all fine yep
yep yep yep yep yep that's one of the
fun things about watching our show the
way that it's written the way that it's
acted in the way it's edited it's so
fast that I've had multiple people say I
had to watch that episode again because
I knew I wasn't getting all the jokes
and I think seven seasons in with an
ensemble cast is really tight with
writers that are really good with a head
writer and showrunner Dan Gore who is
like incredible and so smart and funny I
think you're gonna get like like the
most intense version of the show that
you've ever seen cramming a lot of jokes
people also have all the guest stars you
guys crammed in who's the recurring
character the guest star you want to see
come back this year I think she's a gift
just a treat to be around every day we
were like chatting was like making a new
girlfriend and I absolutely adore her I
think she's wonderful I was I would I
would love for her to come back look
what is this look this is my homage to
cutler's I hope I hope I can do this
great film justice I thought this week
I'm going tomorrow night you were into
you how to see I know I'm going tomorrow
tomorrow I see with every single kind of
guy and I don't know it's like you have
him all figured out
I guess I'm just a people person I don't
know if the story leaves things open for
a sequel but if there is a sequel would
you also want to toss your hat in that
ring I think that story is that
contained world in and of itself but
what is thrilling to me is that there
are so many women working on that
production in all various creative ways
and I think it's really gonna do
something really special for I think
stigmas that are kind of attached to
strippers and sex workers in general I
think people are gonna see this movie
and think twice and I think that's a
wonderful thing for heart to do alright
now we just got to get a female written
and directed she-hulk starring you in
the